nous allons également faire en sorte de
vrai décoller de participer à leur
relance du Parti libéral du Québec nous
avons besoin de discuter d'imaginer
l'avenir faire en sorte de temps de la
main à celles et ceux qui au cours des
années ont quitté le parti libéral du
Québec
je par intérim du parti libéral du
Québec sur les défis qui attendent sa
formation politique au cours des
prochains mois Marc Tanguy va assurer
l'intérim à la direction du PLK après le
départ lundi dernier de Dominique
Anglade et en attendant surtout le choix
du prochain chef les libéraux
devraient-ils se presser de choisir un
prochain chef ou prendre le temps voyons
voir ce qu'on pense mes collaborateurs à
les castonguet et animateur de midi info
à ici première Chantal Hébert et
chroniqueur au Toronto Star et au
magazines d'actualité Michel seoget est
analyste politique à la presse plus
c'est Radio-Canada bonjour à vous trois
bonjour bon commençons par bon
commençons par parler du départ de
Madame Anglade Chantal on en a parlé
depuis l'élection à peu près toutes les
semaines on s'est dit que c'est une
question tendre il y avait plus d'autres
issus il fallait que ça arrive à un
moment donné
non et c'est un rappel au futur chef qui
un jour perdront des élections que le
meilleur scénario c'est de démissionner
le soir même et de s'éviter les jours
qui séparent quelqu'un de l'inévitable
qui est le matin où on se lève pour
démissionner comme on l'a vu en Ontario
lors des élections et aux démocrates les
libéraux les deux chefs avaient
démissionné soit même c'est vrai que
c'est moins long un peu Michel
martanguay le bon choix c'est c'est
l'homme de la situation pour l'intérim
énormément de choix il fallait que ça
soit quelqu'un qui avait été élu dans un
côté francophone il y en avait pas des
douzaines alors oui monsieur Tanguy est
un bourgeois qui est considéré comme
sérieux et aussi partisan parce que ça
vient avec le profil de demander du choc
d'opposition en même temps
c'est quand même très malaisant de voir
qu'on dit ah il va être cher par
atterrir
il pourra se présenter à la chaufferie
s'il veut enfin démissionne avant je
suis pas sûr que c'est quelque chose
d'abord qui fait l'unanimité au sein du
côté cybéral qui se sentent mal à l'aise
avec ça je suis pas sûr que c'est une
bonne façon de nommer un nouveau chef
permanent service d'handicapé les deux
shop en question
je comprends pas que aussi peu de gens
d'entreprise libérale élevé la prélever
la main là-dessus Alex c'est vrai que
c'est un peu bizarre parce qu'en général
les partis politiques quand on a dans
une dans une succession on dit à ceux
qui veulent mesurer l'intérim vous serez
pas de la course pour le vrai chef c'est
le bureau on a décidé de garder ça comme
ça c'est un bon choix
on en déduit qu'il y avait pas beaucoup
de candidats au HF à la par intérim qui
se bousculaient au portillon et qu'on a
peut-être aménagé une clause pour Marc
Tanguay parce que si on avait eu
peut-être d'autres choix vous savez sur
les les vins députés qui vont rester au
Parti libéral la moitié ont été élu pour
la première fois donc évidemment tu
deviens pas chef pas intérim la première
fois il en reste une dizaine Michel
mentionné les compter francophones il y
en a pas beaucoup bref Marc Tanguy était
pas mal le seul choix qu'il restait à
partir du moment où André Fortin dit ben
moi je vais pas prendre l'intérim parce
que je vais me présenter à la chefferie
et le marque Tanguy vous laisse garder
les portes ouvertes puis on lui a
aménagé quelque chose mais le malaise
dont parle Michel il est tout à fait
vrai parce que Marc Tanguay va pendant
plusieurs mois c'est pas des années
parce que la course pourrait déboucher
seulement dans deux ans et demi il va
avoir beaucoup de visibilité va choisir
les officiers du parti quel dossier on
donne à quel porte-parole donc
évidemment il y a un rôle important au
centre de la stratégie puis peut-être
que des André Fortin mon chef des ragi
qui pense à se présenter
je trouvais ça moins drôle certains
jours que un potentiel concurrent et
autant d'espace là au parti libérale on
verra s'il se présente mais c'est vrai
que c'est une situation assez nusitée
qu'on a pas vu à ma connaissance là dans
l'histoire récente de tout autre partie
deux ans ça veut dire que pendant des
mois
un chef intégrément pour être en selle
et tout à coup se déclarer candidat à la
direction du parti
je sais pas il y a une absence de
logique là-dedans
et de logique et d'intelligence
politique dans le sens où pour l'unité
du caucus c'est une situation qui est
qui va inévitablement mener des malaises
et à des crises et c'est pour ça
normalement qui est parti agissent
différemment quant au calendrier je
comprends l'idée d'attendre un an et
demi deux ans ça s'est vu avant mais
attention quelque part si François
Legault lui-même commence à réfléchir à
son avenir le prochain chef libéral
pourrait être élu dans un moment qui va
passer à la trappe parce que la
coalition à venir Québec va être sur le
point de se lancer dans le même genre
d'exercice alors il y a un pensée du
bien là-dedans
moi je pense que ce qui serait dans
l'intérieur du parti libérale c'est que
le chef intégralement soit intérimaire
et qu'il le déclare rapidement voilà bon
ça ouvre la porte sur à quelle vitesse
c'est ce qu'on devrait lancer cet
exercice là Michel il y a deux écoles de
pensée qui disent de nous le temps de
d'autres ils disent ben réglons-en ça
rapidement parce que ça nous permet
d'avoir un chef permanent à celle qui
peut tout de suite aller s'installer à
période de questions puis commencer
si on veut aller très rapidement dans
les faits ça restreint le la course au
députés des jeux élus ou à peu près là
il peut toujours y avoir 45 heures ils
vont être avec un gros désavantage si on
prend plus de temps ça le désavantage de
ne pas aider l'équipe parlementaire
c'est un chef temporaire happy bon tout
le monde va parler de la course qui se
passe dans le parti à l'Assemblée
nationale mais ça laisse le temps
peut-être d'avoir des candidats
d'extérieur et peut-être d'avoir une
meilleure lecture la situation politique
vous savez les deuxièmes c'est jamais
aussi facile que le premier des fois
très rapidement dans un deuxième mandat
comment ça constater des faiblesses du
côté du gouvernement c'est des choses
que le position mais bien sûr essayer
d'exploiter si elle ne peut parlons des
candidats maintenant parce que là Alex
vous avez mentionné deux noms tout à
l'heure qui circulent André Fortin mon
chef des ragies il y a Joël lightband
qui a pas dit non il y a pas dit oui
mais qui a pas dit non j'entends
est-ce que d'autres non du circule
est-ce que danser non là il y a des
candidats qui sont plus intéressants que
d'autres
il est vraiment trop tôt pour pour le
savoir je pense que les trois noms qui
circulent ou qui font circuler leur nom
dans cette période-là
est-ce que ça existe surtout c'est qu'il
y a pas de candidats évident on n'est
pas dans le genre de dynamique ou pas le
Martin va remplacer Jean-Chrétien ou
Justin Trudeau va battre tout le monde
ce qui veut dire qu'il y a une vraie
course et on va savoir ce que valent ces
candidats en fonction de la course ce
qui rend l'idée qu'on va être dans le no
man's land de pas encore de course
pendant un an si on fait ça quelque part
en 2024 un petit peu saugrenu parce que
ils vont devoir alors ceux qui sont à
l'Assemblée nationale faire leur preuve
là avec un chef intégrément qui
peut-être est en train de se préparer
une campagne au leadership en se faisant
valoir à la période des questions c'est
un petit peu tout croche ok bon
combinaison un peu particulière on verra
mais au moins la crise la crise du
leadership de Madame anglaise se sont on
a tourné la page là dessus ça veut pas
dire que la traversée du désert des
libéraux québécois est terminé
j'aimerais vous faire sauter sur la
sainte fédérale en fait fédérale
provincial parce que cette semaine
première rencontre la semaine dernière
première rencontre des ministres de la
Santé en personne avant couvert pour
parler de financement
les provinces sont sortis déchus
monsieur Duclos a dit ben moi je suis
prête à faire des bouts mais j'aimerais
peut-être avoir des concessions de votre
part alors qu'est-ce qu'on retient vous
pensiez vous que les provinces à leur
venir avec un chèque avec une promesse
plus ferme que ce qu'il y avait sur la
table ce qui semble être le cas on
dirait que les provinces françaises
même pas fini de rencontrer ces
homologues des provinces avant couvert
mardi que déjà la Conseil de la
Fédération avait mis un communiqué de
presse disant que c'est un échec
retentissant alors moi je pense que on
savait pas mal dans les provinces que ça
allait être un échec parce qu'on est au
début c'est négociations là ça prend
toujours du temps il y a une certaine
ouverture à Ottawa dis on est prêt à
augmenter le financement ça c'est déjà
un aveu qu'on a pas toujours entendu
dans le passé maintenant de quoi va-t-on
accompagner cette hausse là de quel type
de norme de clause de conditions c'est
sûr que les provinces ne veulent pas et
c'est un bras de fer qui me semble-t-il
depuis que je couvre des discussions sur
des transports fédéraux pas toujours
court les provinces veulent pas de
conditions on va t'avoir puis on finit
par soit avoir un front commun qui se
fissure ou Ottawa qui met de l'eau dans
son vin puis on trouve une façon de
s'entendre parce qu'en bout de piste les
provinces ont besoin de cet argent là
puis Ottawa il y a une limite à dire non
étant donné qu'on voit bien à quel état
le système de santé actuel dans toutes
les provinces pas seulement au Québec
est rendu alors je pense qu'on est au
début d'une partie et non je ne
m'attendais pas à ce qui est de grands
résultats par contre ce qu'on construit
là dans le rapport de force dans la
discussion à une importance pour les
semaines à venir j'attends Michel
je pense d'abord ça fait deux ans que
Justin Trudeau dit qu'il est prêt à
augmenter les transferts en santé alors
je comprends qu'à force de dire ça
redevienne nouvelle à chaque fois qu'il
y a une réunion mais il y en a jamais
dit plus sinon qui voulait boire des
résultats pour son argent il voulait des
façons de vérifier je pense que j'ai
compris que j'ai un petit clos s'est
présenté là en pensant qu'il y avait les
éléments de quelque chose qui pourrait
ressembler à du progrès et c'est pour ça
qu'il est rentré là en disant on
pourrait mettre nos données partager nos
données mettre en place un système pour
partager nos données ce que je comprends
c'est que du côté d'Ottawa on avait
l'impression qu'on avait un grand bout
de chemin de fil là-dessus et qui serait
possible de sortir de la réunion en
disant on a une espèce d'accord informel
sur ce concept-là c'est prometteur et
donc monsieur Duclos pourra rentrer à
Ottawa et dire Justin Trudeau bonne idée
patron d'inviter les patrons pour
essayer d'arriver à une vraie entente
c'est pas ça qui s'est passé du tout et
à Ottawa on a eu l'impression qu'on
s'est fait tirer le tapis de sous les
pieds je pense que j'arrive du Clos
lui-même le dit son impression son
interprétation c'est que ses collègues
qui étaient prêts à jouer dans son film
c'était fait dire par leur patron
attention nous on veut pas ça on veut
que vous teniez la ligne il faut que je
syndrudo nous rencontre nous donne de
l'argent je sais pas pourquoi il les
rencontre là d'ailleurs c'est tout ce
qu'on veut c'est de l'argent sans
condition il y aurait pu dire qu'ils
mettent un chèque à la poste et on passe
à autre chose mais ce que c'est illustre
c'est le changement de la carte fédérale
provinciale la dernière fois au début du
mandat Justin Trudeau on avait réussi à
faire des ententes à diviser les
provinces
aujourd'hui la table fédérale
provinciale est beaucoup moins favorable
de Justin Trudeau et les possibilités
d'arriver à ce genre de règlement là
sont beaucoup moins bonnes que la
dernière fois Michel sort la possible de
division cette fracture du Conseil de la
fédération qui a toujours bien servi les
libéraux le gouvernement fédéral mais
mais d'abord est-ce qu'on est rendu
est-ce qu'il faut que ce soit les
premiers ministres qui règle la question
de financement de la santé
c'est toujours
la question du financement de la santé
ça peut pas être autrement d'autre part
quand une fracture et quand on peut
jouer les uns contre les autres parce
que dans Chantal il y a pas encore
d'argent sur la table et si on est au
niveau des grands principes au niveau
des principes les provinces sont
toujours craintes et craignent encore
que dire si on partage nos données ça
c'est ouvrir la porte toute grande à
donner à Ottawa ce qu'il faut pour avoir
des normes nationales en santé ce qui
est à peu près comme comme le diable
pour la plupart des provinces donc on
est pas mal écoutez je trouve ça depuis
quand même un certain nombre d'années ça
fait des décennies qu'on est dans ce
marasme là sans pouvoir en sortir
Ottawa exige des données les provinces
et il y a 13 systèmes différents pour
marche pour maigrir
on peut pas comparer toujours des
problèmes des anges on est encore là
Alex c'est ça la crainte c'est que les
données que le gouvernement fédéral
demande soit utilisé pour retaper sur la
tête des provinces à un moment donné
c'est ça
ouais c'est quand on utilise une
première négociation pour ensuite
élargir en disant maintenant qu'on a les
données on voit bien que ça se passe mal
pour tel tel domaine dans votre province
donc on va lise le financement seulement
à ces domaines-là ok mais moi j'ai aussi
d'autres besoins vous pouvez pas
commencer à me l'imposer alors oui on a
une crainte du côté des provinces mais
elle est légitime elle est là j'ai hâte
de voir combien de temps il va durer
parce que c'est vrai qu'on a pas le même
type de de diviser pour régner que la
dernière fois je suis juste un retour
parce qu'on avait des premiers ministres
des provinces qui étaient libéraux à
l'époque qui était peut-être un peu plus
favorable à faire des entendre avec
Ottawa à la pièce qui est moins le cas
alors que là chantal a raison devant lui
essentiellement des premiers ministres
conservateurs n'empêche quand même
jusqu'à un certain point on va avoir
besoin de cet argent là dans certaines
provinces là il y a des endroits où on
va tenir la ligne moins longtemps que
d'autres alors quand on va arriver avec
l'argent sur la table attends vous
augmente par exemple de 10 12 15
milliards par année est-ce qu'il y en a
des provinces qui vont dire parfait je
vais vous envoyer mon tableau de bord
moi je voudrais si vous voulez avec
peut-être alors c'est là qu'on va voir
si effectivement on les principes vont
venir jusqu'au bout là j'entends il nous
reste une vingtaine de secondes
mais je comprends de ce qui est arrivé
cette semaine c'est que j'ai envie du
Clos à pas dit à Justin Trudeau invité
donc les autres premiers ministres pour
négocier c'est le contraire qui est en
train de se passer et en passant oui les
premiers ministres avec ça de façon
assez simple c'était une un peu il y a
décrété unilatéralement ce qui allait
faire puis envoyer une lettre à ces
homologues pour dire voilà c'est ça
ouais c'est ça ça c'est un autre forme
de négociation fâcheux qu'on appelle ça
négociation en fait on va reprendre ça
quand on aura amené le dossier un peu
plus loin avec Chantal Michel merci
beaucoup
au revoir au revoir